let me ask the kind of political
sounding question which is how people
usually phrase it
did anthony fauci
uh fund gain of function research
at the wuhan institute of virology so it
depends i mean i've obviously been
very closely monitoring this i've spoken
a lot about it i've written about it
and it depends on i mean not to quote
bill clinton but to quote bill clinton
it depends on what the definition of is
is and so um if you use a common sense
definition of gain of function and by
gain of function there are lots of
things like gene therapies that are gain
of function but here what we mean is
gain a function for
pathogens able potentially able to
create
human
pandemics
but if you use the kind of common sense
language well then he probably did if
you use the technical language from a
2017 nih document
and you read that language very narrowly
i think you can make a credible argument
that he that he did not there's a
question though and and uh francis
collins talked about that in his in his
interview with you but then there's a
question that we know uh from now that
we have the information of the reports
submitted by equal health alliance um to
the uh the nih and and some of which
were late or not even delivered that
some of this research was done on mers
middle eastern respiratory syndrome um
virus and if that was the case um there
is a i think a colorable argument that
that would um be considered gain of
function research even by the narrow
language of that 2017 document but i but
i i definitely think
and i've said this repeatedly that rand
paul can be right and tony fauci can be
right and the question is um what how
are we defining gain of function and
that's why i've always said the question
in my mind isn't
was it or wasn't it gain of function as
if that's like a binary thing if if not
great and if yes guilty the question is
just
what work was being done at the wuhan
institute of virology
what
role
if any did u.s
government funding play in
supporting that that work and what
rights do we all have as as
as human beings and as american citizens
and taxpayers to get all of the relevant
information about them so
let's try to kind of
dissect this so who frustrates you more
rand paul
or anthony falcini's discussion or the
discussion itself so for example gain a
function
is a term
that's
kind of more used
uh just to mean
making uh playing with viruses in the
lab to try to develop more dangerous
viruses
is this kind of research
a good idea
is it also
a good idea for us to talk about it in
public in the political way that has
been talked about is it okay
that um
us may have funded gain of functional
research elsewhere i mean it's kind of
assumed
just like with bill clinton
there was very little discussion of uh i
think correct me if i'm wrong but you
know whether it's okay
for a president
male or female
to have extramarital sex okay
or
is it okay
for a president to have
extramarital sex with people on their on
his staff
or her staff
it was more the discussion of lying i
think it was did you did you lie about
having sex or not and in this gain of
function discussion what frustrates me
personally is there's not a deep
philosophical discussion about whether
we should be doing this kind of research
and
what kinds like what are the ethical
lines research on animals at all those
are fascinating questions instead it's a
gotcha thing did you or did you not fund
research and gain a function and
did you fund it's almost like a
bioweapon did you give
money to china to develop this bioweapon
that now attacked the rest of the world
yeah so i mean all
all those things are pretty frustrating
but is there um
i think the thing you can untangle about
anthony fauci and getting functional
research in the united states and equal
health alliance and
mohan institute of virology that's kind
of um
that's clarifying what were the mistakes
made sure so
on gain of function there actually has
been a lot of of debate and i mentioned
before in 2011 these first papers uh
there was a big debate uh mark lipsich
who's formerly at harvard now with the
the
the u.s government uh working in the
president's office um he led a thing
called the cambridge group uh that was
highly critical of this work but
basically saying we're
we're creating monsters they had the
funding pause in 2014 and they spent
three years putting together a framework
and then they they lifted it in 2017. so
we had a thoughtful conversation
unfortunately it didn't work and i think
that's where where we are now so i
absolutely think um that there are real
issues with uh the relationship between
the united states government and eco
health alliance and
through that eco-health alliance with
the wuhan institute of virology and one
issue is just essential transparency
because as i see it it's most likely the
case that we transferred a lot of our
knowledge and plans and things to the
wuhan institute of virology and again
i'm sure that xi jiang li
is not herself a monster i'm sure of
that even though i've never met her
but
there are just a different set of
pressures on people working in an
authoritarian system than people who are
working in other systems that doesn't
mean it's entirely entirely different
and so i absolutely think that we
shouldn't give one dollar
to an organization and certainly a
virology institute where you don't have
full access to to their records to their
databases we don't know what work is is
is happening there
and i think that we need to have
that kind of full examination and that's
why so i understand
what what dr fauci is doing is saying
hey what i hear dr fatty thing what i
hear from you rand paul
is you're accusing me of starting this
pandemic and you're using gain of
function as a proxy for that and we have
in when there are senate hearings every
senator gets five minutes and the name
of the game is to translate your five
minutes into a clip that's going to run
on the news and so i get that there is
but i also think that uh the dr fauci
and uh the nia the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases and the
nih should have been more transparent um
because i i think that
in this day and age where there are a
lot of people poking around and this
whole story of covert origins uh we
would not be where we are if it wasn't
for a relatively small number of people
and and i'm i'm part of there are two as
i know two groups one is these internet
sleuths known as drastic and a number of
them are part of a group um that i'm
part of called it's it's not our
official name but called the paris group
it's about two dozen
experts
around the world but centered around
some some very
high level french academics so we've all
been digging
and meeting with each other regularly
since
since last year and our governments
across the board certainly china but
including the united states haven't been
as transparent as they as they
they need to be so
there's definitely mistakes were made on
all sides and that's why for me from day
one
i've been calling for a comprehensive
investigation into this issue that
certainly obviously looks at china but
we have to look at ourselves we did not
get this right
you